[Music]  yesterday afternoon we had one of those  police chases here in Los Angeles one of  those ones with the local news  helicopters following overhead and they  were chasing this is true they were  chasing a guy suspected of being  intoxicated and he was driving a van for  a local energy company called American  solar direct well this happened  yesterday the company today responded  with a brand-new ad they want us to show  look to American solar direct for all  your solar energy needs our highly  trained technicians will rush to your  home to install the latest inside  technology  common obstacles that would slow lessor  companies are merely brushed aside an  American solar DUI stands for driving  uber fast to your installation you don't  catch us lying down on the job  American solar direct  [Applause]  [Music]  that's not that's not the publicity that  company good luck  [Laughter]